my name is rubella posh and I thought
that this morning would be maybe
interesting to explain to you my method
of working it's more fun to tell stories
as a group and it's more fun and richer
to take everybody's experience and
disciplines and make them converge
together so it's not starting with that
idea it's it's letting it appear and
imposing itself and that will bring us
to our resource today ex machina is
working on a new piece based on playing
cards
the project is called playing cards we
believe that the content is isn't here
you know that there's tons of stories in
this and I believe that if we give you
that resource that you actually can come
up with your own interpretation so it's
a family thing at least one thing we
could try this afternoon and the
playfulness visit we try to play cards
just play cards just do that
the last thing I wonder step take some
time to to do which is something I
always try to do as part of the
exploration thing say well just do like
one big collective drawing there's no
rules to this you just draw the
impressions that you have what we did
together today about cards whatever
we're just gonna quickly go around
everybody just to know what who
contributed what I did this purple
figure that people turn into a train
yeah what's that
the number of cards that you need for
the hand and poker is an interesting
pattern I would experience we've learned
that we should not force connections we
let them and eventually two three things
seems to go together and we go oh
there's a pattern there and then we sit
and we score his approach to things is
so different from the classical approach
where you start with the script versus
this collaborative effort where it's
everyone sort of tries to shape it in
their own way probably over the next
month or so
month and a half that we have we're
gonna be generating new material but
also trying to think about how material
can be threaded together into some kind
of coherent production so I'm kind of
looking forward to finding out what it
ends up being one when the pressure is
not any questions any any doubts and
fears have fun that's the most important
thing be playful
one of the things that is really
interesting to me about Lapage his
approach is that he creates a space
where people feel safe to share their
stories to try new things and that's
really what we've tried to do here
these students are largely meditating on
their families on their experiences as
young people experiencing love for the
first time so they're very personal
stories all centered around family it is
two weeks from tonight two weeks from
tonight Lapage will come with some
additional people from ex machina and
they will watch a series of scenes that
we've developed over the course of the
semester I think we're all a little
nervous but I think in the end I'm
taking as a cue his his sort of dictate
that we should play and so that Tuesday
is less of us showing a final project
but showing the results of our semester
of play
this is something that we're we're
excited to share with you and it's
something in process that I'm excited to
to show you all the rough edges so enjoy
and really happy sweet nature
well congratulations there's some great
ideas and usually it's at this this
point it's still the ideas are very
imprecise and chaotic and this is not
the case I realize how it was like we
could just break it down and build it up
and like we were just playing with clay
we used the collaborative drawing that
we made on the first day many of the
ideas came out of improvisation around
that we started with probably a memory
and then as we went on and if it got
stale or we got stuck we've tried to
distort and augment it and then it came
for like full circle back to something
true I think the best thing of all is
that you have an amazing sense of
character out of all of those
interesting ideas what's important is
the sense of character to which we can
relate to that we can recognize
ourselves into another I think it's
great work and I'm so flabbergasted how
well produced at all is at this day